Kate I'll come your way first weird
Barbie speaks to me but I imagine this
is the type of character that you can't
fully process just on the page alone so
what's the biggest difference between
how you first Envision weird Barbie when
you read the script and then who she
became the more you dug into the role
and played in the the set with the
costume all that good stuff it was
pretty similar like I read it and I was
like oh okay she wrote this perfect I
don't have to change a word I get it I
know what it is the costume was it
involved as sort of a and imagining and
I was like what does she wear because
weird Barbies typically have been
stripped of all of their clothes and
possessions but I didn't want to be
naked in the movie so I I thought about
um would a person have reappropriated
sort of a baby doll dress and put it on
the Barbie
um what household items would be
available to put on the barbie so
um that was a surprise but the rest was
really just like they wrote it so good
it didn't need much every single Barbie
my sister had was a weird Barbies now
all I could picture was a Barbie land
filled with weird Barbies that'd be her
world and I love it I would watch that
movie I would love that movie uh Michael
for you I am curious let's say Alan took
over Barbie land what would what might
it look like what song would be playing
in the car what movie would he be
watching if not Cowboys and horses what
would the dominant theme be it's a
really difficult question because
Alan he's sort of he sort of recedes as
a character
um
I guess he would he would definitely not
want to listen to that Ken song any
anymore ever again I don't know what did
Alan like to listen to you think
yeah he was discontinued in 1967. so
he's sort of like that's like the limbo
that he lives in so maybe like Crimson
and Clover
Forever on a loop people are dogging on
it Alan's kids are fed you know Alan has
Insurance on everything Alan is doing
great Alan's holding it down Alan's
partner is very happy with him and it's
fine Ellen rocks Helen does Rock Justice
for Alan always uh Isa for you a behind
the scenes question because I love your
work on camera but I also am a big
admirer of all of your producing work
and I love what this movie does in that
respect so having worked on Barbie is
there anything you were all able to
accomplish on this film that kind of
like illuminated the possibilities of
making a bold movie like this with a
really strong voice that you know you
might want to pursue as a producer going
forward to be 100 honest
I've been like IP fatigued you know I'm
just like why does every movie have to
be happy but to see what Greta and I
were able to do with this family they
made it their own and it was fun and
they were able to make fun of Mattel in
a way and Mattel embraced that they got
to write essentially what they wanted
like Margot didn't think that this would
be made and it seemed like they
accomplished a lot of what they set out
to do so it gave me hope that you know
what it's not something that I'll pursue
actively first but that if it comes my
way I won't I won't rebuke it well now
that I'm curious is there any particular
IP that speaks to you where it's got
like an untapped creative Corner that
you would go after I haven't thought
about that
um I don't have to get back to you on
that maybe
yeah I I don't know I don't know fair
enough whatever it winds up being sign
me up for it I am here anyone feel free
to chime in on this I'm a big fan of
Greta's can you tell me something about
her as a collaborator an actor's
director that makes her stand out and
you hope to experience on future
projects you work on smiling every
second she has she is indefatigable I've
never seen someone with so much pure joy
and energy and collaborative Spirit just
literally sucking the best out of
everyone around her it was just I was
like how is she still standing and
having this much energy and enthusiasm
it was amazing
perfectly good she made me not want to
be the director because I will never
have my friend
on that set so thank you for crushing
any ambition you also you feel like
she's noticing everything you're doing
yeah there's so much happening and you
feel like she's paying attention to you
know to the actors and she's really
you know really focused on actors you
know um and so relaxed within this giant
Machinery to just make stuff I mean it
was someone she was like maybe at the
end we should do this instead of just
able to sort of extemporize even with
these millions of dollars being spent
every day incredibly impressive
I admire they keep me coming back for
more same for all three of you and
everything you do thank you for your
time thank you